-Oh, my goodness!
Happy Thanksgiving, everybody.
I hope everyone had a great day.
Today is just about over,
and I just thought
I'd take a look
at my Thanksgiving bingo card.
-Oh.
-Might as well.
I already had dinner.
Let's see how I did here.
Okay, first up in this square,
we have...
Yeah.
Devin? It was Terran.
This next square says...
Ah! There's a lot
of summer soaps.
Some are real. Who knows?
Let's see. So I got --
I'm two for two.
-Two for two, dude.
-Yeah.
Let's see this next square here.
[ Laughter ]
-Mid.
-Wow.
-Didn't happen to me.
Let's take a look
at this next one here.
[ Laughter ]
[Sleepily] "Hey, dude.
-"Hey, man.
-What are we eatin', man?"
Fake turkey, dude!"
-You got any Funyuns, dude?"
Alright. Uh, that didn't happen.
Oh, well, here's the free space.
Okay, well, that's --
Everyone gets that one.
Of course.
The next square says...
-Oh.
-Not this year.
Not this year, thankfully.
-Last year.
-Yeah, last year.
That's a different story.
How about this one?
-Ooh.
-What do you know?
What do you know?
That didn't happen to me.
How about this one here?
Actually did happen to me.
I'll take that one.
And finally...
the Roomba
Oh, that's -- Hey, I got bingo!
-Yeah!
I got Thanksgiving bingo!
Alright!